[Música]
en primera plana
carlos hola que tal bienvenidos en
primera plana un programa de radio
france internacional y de france 24 esta
semana ponemos el foco en brasil
epicentro mundial de la pandemia para
ello me acompañan ya en este estudio
tres invitados a quien les presento
saben grande adam es periodista
independiente especializada en
latinoamérica bienvenida a sabin gracias
pequeño
gaspar estrada director ejecutivo del
observatorio para américa latina y el
caribe del instituto de ciencias
sociales de aquí de parís bienvenido
señor estrada hola carlos un gusto estar
contigo
cristian capuchino compañera periodista
de la redacción brasileña de recibió en
venid a cristian brasil el centro de la
pandemia y la controvertida gestión del
presidente por sonar hoy en primera
plana
brasil superó ya hace días esa barrera
de cuatro mil muertos diarios
relacionada con el coronavirus a los
desafíos sanitarios agravados por nuevas
cepas del virus se añade una gran crisis
política por la cuestionada gestión del
gobierno de bolsón euro las
instituciones brasileñas como el senado
ya han dado el primer paso para
investigar al presidente por la
responsabilidad que tenga que pueda
tener en toda esta crisis bolsonaro que
por cierto sigue negando la gravedad de
la pandemia dice que los medios exageran
mientras que cada vez más países como el
caso de francia suspenden sus vuelos con
brasil por miedo a esa temida cepa
brasileña del virus repasamos algunas
portadas que nos deja la prensa folha de
sao paulo
el senado va a investigar la gestión de
jair bolsonaro el correo correio
braziliense corrígeme si me equivoco en
este gen aporta en esta otra portada un
dato estremecedor varias ciudades de
brasil que tienen ya más muertes que
nacimientos en lo que va de mes de abril
la versión brasileña del diario español
el país titulado de hace unos días
récord de muertes con cuatro mil ciento
95 en un solo día que vaticinan un mes
de abril trágico en brásil
bueno saben sin pretender editorializar
e intentando que la pregunta no sea
retórica como hemos llegado a este punto
de cuatro mil muertos diarios en brasil
y que el presidente bolsonaro siga con
ese discurso de que los medios estamos
exagerando la pandemia 4.000 muertos
diarios 4.000 muertos en diarios y 30
por ciento por 37% de las personas que
mueren en el mundo del cómic son
brasileños
pues para contestar yo opino que como
muchos que eso resulta de una estrategia
del gobierno brasileño y que no es
incompetencia negligencia sino una
estrategia calculada de diseminar la
pandemia del contagio para llegar a una
inmunización colectiva después y
cristian me gustaría cuéntenos cómo es
la situación ahora mismo en los
hospitales brasileños y cuáles son ahora
mismo los focos más críticos bueno los
hospitales están abarrotados tenemos
problemas en muchos en muchos estados
pero sobre todo en el sur el sudeste de
brasil y ahí está la más grande parte de
la población brasileña lo que promete en
abril trágico consell mil muertes
tenemos al falta de insumos de
medicamentos para sedación entubación
encima de la falta de vacunas
gaspar los votantes de bolsonaro se
avienen ese mensaje del presidente o hay
o hay al menos crítica con ello con ese
mensaje de que los medios están
exagerando hay una adhesión a ese
mensaje bueno me parece que el punto
relevante es que la base electoral de
bolsonaro sigue estando bastante firme a
pesar de todos estos números que son
realmente escalofriantes
y hoy según las encuestas entre 25 y 30
por ciento de los brasileños siguen
aprobando la gestión de bolsonaro en
particular es un electorado que está
dividido en dos este por un lado hay un
electorado de una población
mayoritariamente humilde este de
confesión evangélica también hay
muchos policías miembros de policías
militares en los estados y por otro lado
también el gran empresariado es decir
las las élites están divididas siguen
respaldando a bolsonaro aunque hay cada
vez más una cierta toma de distancia con
relación a las medidas implementadas por
el gobierno
bolsonaro está claro que con la
degradación de la economía por un lado y
por otro lado la grabación de la
pandemia
pues no es seguro que está que está que
está base electoral de bolsonaro se
mantenga en estos niveles de aquí a la
elección presidencial del 2022 el senado
ha anunciado una comisión para
investigar las responsabilidades de
bolsonaro en toda esta crisis les
pregunto sabino cristian quien quiere
responderme que puede salir de esta
investigación y hasta dónde puede llegar
bueno lo que se espera es que se
muestran todos los problemas en el
ministro de las de la salud en el
ministerio de la salud
tuvimos cuatro ministros de la salud
mientras la pandemia eso es más que los
ministros de todo el gobierno dilma con
casi seis años y ahí no tuvo compras de
vacunas no tuvo compras de insumos ni de
oxígeno en el peor momento demandados
por ejemplo entonces despierta sé que
hay quien salga los responsables del
gobierno federal por la situación que
tenemos ahora si eso va a empezar un
proceso de íntima o algo así y ya no se
sabe
no se sabe si este proceso va a poder
hacer resaltar también las
responsabilidades del presidente mismo
no solamente de sus ministros ministros
de la salud de los cuales el último el
pañuelo que es un general reconocía el
mismo que no entendía nada de salud
pública ni ni de medidas sanitarias ni
nada entonces este proceso va a poner
palabras colocar palabras en los hechos
de los de las decisiones del gobierno
que fueron no solamente erróneas sino
quizás estratégicamente pensadas para
para contener la pandemia dicen los
expertos que mientras el virus siga
circulando a esta velocidad en brasil
podrían surgir otras cepas como la con
tan contagiosa p1 esta circunstancia y
la presión internacional cada vez más
países aquí en europa como por ejemplo
francia que suspenden los vuelos
no haya más presión cada vez sobre las
autoridades brasileñas
bueno por un lado claramente el gobierno
revolucionario es un gobierno aislado en
el plano internacional el gobierno cosa
no está pagando el costo de la opción
que tomó desde el inicio de su mandato
en 2019 que fue un alineamiento
unilateral sobre bueno funciona eeuu el
gobierno de donald trump ahora con el
gobierno validen claramente esta apuesta
es una apuesta fallida también vemos
cambios ese aislamiento parece que ahora
intenta hacerlo menos con la dimisión de
araujo del ex canciller brasileño ahí se
ve por una posición y digamos más
pragmática o intentar ciertos
movimientos el problema es que ahí hay
una contradicción porque por un lado
efectivamente araujo salió de la
cancillería a raíz de una presión muy
fuerte de estos sectores internacionales
pero también la presión interna en
particular del senado brasileño sin
embargo a pesar de que hubo un nuevo
hay un nuevo canciller en brasil con un
discurso más pragmático más abierto
luego lo que le interesa eeuu y lo que
le interesa
by denny a la comunidad internacional es
ver resultados en el tema de la lucha
contra el cambio climático y la lucha
contra la deforestación en la amazonía y
eso no está llevándose a cabo porque el
discurso de evolucionar el día de hoy
decir de aquí a 2030 brasil dejará de
dejar de producir
de la tala de bosques es decir a habrá
habrá que poner punto final a la tala
ilegal el problema es que no tenemos que
pensar en 2030 brasil tiene que tomar
acciones hoy para combatir el cambio
climático y eso bolsonaro no está
dispuesto a hacerlo porque es su base
electoral que no quiere siquiera que ni
siquiera cree entonces desde ese punto
de vista está claro que hay una
contradicción que va a quedar cada vez
más clara y que va a poner en
dificultades a bolsonaro cristian hay
una presión internacional pero a lo
tocante de las cepas hay que decir que
para controlar tenemos que teníamos que
hacer un log dan ahora pero para eso hay
que los alcaldes tienen que tomar la
decisión pero un soporte económico del
gobierno federal es necesario para que
la gente no sea empujada a las calles
por la necesidad en ese movimiento
el gobierno bolsonaro no lo hace hay una
pequeña ayuda algo como 50 dólares por
familia mucho menos lo que hubo en 2020
entonces mientras no
o hace algo por la economía como por las
ayudas a la gente no se hace nada por
darle lo que dan y sólo la presión no
pueden cambiar lo que la gente hace en
cada ciudad
y no solamente las ayudas económicas a
la población brasileña sino que
evolucionado retuvo las ayudas
económicas a los estados que vivían al
sistema sanitario las retuvo se negó a
comprar vacunas se negó a mandar los
insumos equipamientos y los presupuestos
para la sanidad a los estados y bueno
son acciones repetidas de rechazo a todo
todo tipo de acción para contener el
contagio ya todo está el ritmo de
vacunación es lento la poco más del 10
por ciento tiene ya la primera dosis y
además un efecto un poco raro cristiana
hay gente que no ha acudido a por la
segunda dosis según relata la prensa del
país no sé a qué se debe esta
circunstancia quizá la desinformación no
también es así pero también hay muchas
cosas de ahí tal vez algo de la
coordinación porque en un gobierno u
otro siempre fue el ministerio que usó
hizo él
nacional de inmunización entonces
sabíamos que quien iba a ser vacunado
cuando en todo el país igual y ahora no
se sabe cada alcalde decide quién va a
vacunar entonces en una ciudad sabes que
los psicólogos han sido considerados
como gente de la sanidad es son
prioritarios en la otra son los
educadores en la otra son la gente de
mayor de 60 años en la otra de 80
entonces hay un problema de información
que no sabes cuándo puede tomar la
vacuna en tu ciudad vemos problema de
desinformación gaspar y una y una
gestión de la pandemia absolutamente
kafkiana y una creo que es la palabra y
que va a tener consecuencias durables y
muy graves para el cual futuro del país
el hecho que como lo mencionaba allá hoy
en día en brasil más muertos que en
nacimientos pues dice mucho sobre el
estado de brasil
y esperemos que los gobiernos locales
intenten pues salvar lo que es posible
porque claramente estamos ante una
situación de caos
frente al sistema de salud brasileño que
era uno de los mejores del mundo muy
bien organizado muy eficiente y ahora
que se ve destrozado destrozado por
todos todas las contradicciones y
acciones contrarias del gobierno federal
en contra del ministerio de la salud y
del sistema y como mencionaba todo está
desorganizado por tantos actos
contrarios que se oponen a que se haga
una acción coordinada de vacunación por
ejemplo bueno con todo este escenario
vamos a plantearnos unos instantes a la
vuelta de pausa cómo quedan las cosas de
cara al futuro político del país a 2022
se va en unos instantes en primera plana
todas las semanas tenemos una cita para
hablar de mujeres en ellas hoy hablamos
de nuestra diversidad nuestros logros y
nuestras luchas constantes aquí
entrevistamos a las que generan el
cambio en el mundo y les contamos sus
historias
[Música]
el día soy en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
france24 punto com está disponible en
cuatro idiomas artículos reportajes
noticias internacionales continuamente
todas nuestras ediciones para ver de
nuevo y el canal en directo 24 horas los
7 días intuitivo rápido y en cuatro
lenguas france24 puntocom liberté
égalité actualice
[Música]
continuamos en primera plana esta semana
ponemos el foco en brasil epicentro
mundial de la pandemia lo hacemos con la
periodista sabin grande de anv con
gaspar estrada director ejecutivo del
observatorio para américa latina y el
caribe del instituto de ciencias
políticas de parís y con mi compañera
cristiane capuchinos de la redacción
brasileña de reflexión por cierto cómo
lleva este momento tan grave de crisis
en el país el brasil de los olvidados
porque tengo tiene una estadística casi
117 millones de brasileños que vivieron
con algún grado de inseguridad
alimenticia en los últimos tres meses de
2020 117 millones de personas nos
referimos al brasil que ya no tiene
trabajo que ahora dependen de las ayudas
del estado que hace el cien por cien sin
dinero sin comida y sin vacuna
desafortunadamente tenemos que decir que
en brasil la hambre
-volvió hay mucha gente que no sabe lo
que va a comer además en mañana entonces
hay por eso explica por qué la gente
está en las calles está en el por qué el
lock down de alguno que algunas alcaldes
intentaron hacer no se puede y como no
se puede sustentar este
las medidas de restricción sin dinero
lo que pasa es que tienen que hacer una
una escoja que es que es imposible o
sabes para entender a tener lo que comer
es después el comité o te quedas en casa
sin nada
sales claro la ayuda económica que se
distribuyó en el gobierno durante meses
y que se terminó en diciembre y
normalmente volverá vuelve ahora ayudó
un poco a contener esa pobreza pero
ahora después de que se terminara la
ayuda la gente volvió a caer como dices
en el hambre y en la obligación absoluta
de salir de casa para comer para buscar
comida y con trabajo y es informal
informal y así importante de decir que
en el año de 2020 que tenía una ayuda
por adulto que era algo como 100 dólares
ahora el goya no volvió es la nada con
la mitad de word hogar entonces eso eso
no es el suficiente para que la gente
tiene lo que comer encima el dolor es
mucho está muy caro entonces la comida
hubo tuvo una inflación enorme
algunos medios dicen subrayan que los
números de la pobreza en brasil
volverían a su índice de antes de los
años lula
antes de todas las políticas sociales
que hizo lula y eso es lo comentábamos
en esa circunstancia y que varias
ciudades brasileñas ya registren más
muertes que nacimientos debido a la
pandemia el pasado mes de marzo el más
mortífero hasta ahora de la crisis en
brasil falleció más gente de la que
nació en al menos 12 de las 50 urbes con
más de 500 mil habitantes algo no ha
sido una situación que se multiplicó en
río de janeiro en portoalegre o en natal
es decir y además según los expertos
demográficos que puede tener
consecuencias incluso estructurales para
el país es decir más allá además de toda
esta catástrofe de la gestión de toda
esta catástrofe económica consecuencias
estructurales en el país pues ya y eso y
eso es lo que es gravísimo cuando uno
piensa en cómo bolsonaro llegó al poder
y como como bolsonaro construir este
discurso anti política y ver las
consecuencias de haber llevado a
bolsonaro al poder porque no sólo hay
este problema demográfico a futuro sino
este problema sanitario brasil tenía
políticas tenía
tanto en la investigación como en el
plano de la aplicación de las vacunas
pero lo vemos en todos los campos en la
cultura en la educación en la ciencia y
tecnología brasil ya no distribuye
bolsas es decir estímulos para la
producción científica entonces en todas
las políticas públicas y eso sin hablar
de la educación en el medio ambiente
entonces desde ese punto de vista lo que
vemos retrocesos en todos los campos y
eso es lo que es muy preocupante de cara
al futuro pues vamos a escarbar un
poquito en la realidad política porque
si lo recuerdan hace un par de semanas
hubo una crisis política dentro del
gobierno de bolsonaro a partir del
relevo de su ministro de asuntos
exteriores también el de defensa y
algunos cambios más en el ejecutivo
hablamos antes con gaspar esa pretensión
de relevar al ex canciller
ernesto araújo que era tener unas
posiciones muy ultra conservadoras y muy
para hacerlo para buscar una posición
más pragmática a nivel internacional que
hay detrás de estos cambios dentro del
gabinete bolsonaro gaspar bueno lo que
hay es una voluntad del presidente
devolución a lo de retomar la iniciativa
política en después del regreso a la
cancha electoral del ex presidente lula
que ha puesto al ejecutivo en la
defensiva claramente me parece que
tentativa fue una tentativa fallida
porque porque una insubordinación del
ejército los comandantes de las tres
fuerzas renunciaron a raíz de la
dimisión del ministro de defensa que era
un militar y esto generó una crisis
dentro del ejército que era hasta hasta
ahora uno de los pilares de sustentación
del gobierno
bolsonaro y me parece que que a raíz de
estas malas noticias económicas el
centro aunque es este grupo de partidos
de centroderecha que también ha sido
desde el año pasado uno de los pilares
del gobierno de bolsonaro pues va a
aumentar cada vez más el precio para
respaldar al gobierno de bolsonaro
entonces yo creo que ya sea a nivel de
sus partidos de centroderecha ya sea a
nivel del ejército y el sector
empresarial que cada vez está más
incómodo en está de apoyo al gobierno de
bolsonaro bueno vemos que los tres
pilares de sustentación de evolucionar
pues están perdiendo consistencia y esto
pues claramente no es una buena señal
para evolucionar
a lo que refería tangencialmente gaspar
en esa vuelta de lula porque el supremo
acaba de ratificar hace unas horas esa
decisión de la justicia de considerar al
ex juez sergio moro como parcial en el
juicio que condenado en 2017 al ex
presidente lula da silva por corrupción
y lavado de dinero anuló todo el proceso
y por ende lula podrá volver a
presentarse a la presidencia en 2022 es
una decisión que repito acaba de ser
ratificada hace unas horas por el
supremo y adonde esto nos conduce a un
choque irremediable en 2022 entre
bolsonaro y lula cristian en este
movimiento sí porque tenemos dos fuerzas
que en todos los encuestas tienen más
que 30 por ciento de los de los votantes
pero todavía tenemos un año y pico hasta
las elecciones una pandemia a enfrentar
en muchas cosas podrían cambiar entonces
antes sabíamos que evolucionar estaría
en el segundo turno seguramente ahora es
lula que está seguramente en el segundo
turno pero vamos a con ésta con este
escenario vamos hacia un
un escenario 2022 más polarizado todavía
más polarizado o todavía polarizado como
antes creo que claramente vamos a un
duelo entre bolsonaro y lula
por el momento no hay una tercera vía
que se vea probable sino una tercera vía
que podría ser más golpista más golpista
porque personalmente yo temo de que he
evolucionado acorralado como ésta podría
puedes sentar la presión sobre sobre el
congreso y hacer bueno manipular de tal
manera para por ejemplo se ha dado el
congreso
voy a transformar a esta lo que se
refiere esa vida en una pregunta porque
mucho se habla de la posición de la
relación actual de los militares y
bolsonaro con qué apoyos cuenta ahora
mismo bolsonaro dentro del cuerpo
militar
gaspar bueno yo creo que esa es una
pregunta central que hay que hacerse
porque porque hay la posición de los
militares es muy ambigua porque porque
por un lado los militares ocupan una
posición central en el gobierno como
nunca se había visto en brasil desde el
fin de la dictadura militar romana de
arroz que nunca más de una tercera parte
de los ministros del gobierno de bolt
sonados son militares los militares
controlan más de seis mil cargos de
dirección en los ministerios en las
empresas públicas entonces se trata de
un gobierno eminentemente militar o al
menos que en el cual el componente
militar es central entonces ellos han
recuperado un espacio en la vida pública
y tienen un prestigio dentro del
gobierno ahora bien por otro lado los
gobiernos de los militares no quieren
ser asociados al desastre cada vez más
evidente del gobierno
bolsonaro es en este sentido que los
comandantes de las tres fuerzas deciden
renunciar a sus cargos en protesta por
la dimisión del ministro de defensa no
quieren ver que el gobierno que el
ejército es usado con fines políticos
por bolsonaro que ha sido toda su
estrategia desde hace ya varios meses o
sea si nada de esas no quieren claro
pero el problema que no lo ven los
cuarteles no es cierto pero es que tener
cierta o decir que los que los generales
no quieren porque los gobiernos
generales ganan dinero gracias al
gobierno son ministros de hecho el que
maneja la economía el que encarnó el
discurso del gobierno en este año sobre
el tema central del momento que es la
pandemia era un militar el general para
suelo que era ministro de salud entonces
el ejército es asociado a este a esta
tragedia y él y el ejército tiene un
problema político que resolver no sé qué
con bolsonaro o va a tener en algún
momento tener que tomar una decisión
entonces eso es un problema porque el
ejército no tiene que ocupar en un país
democrático el espacio que hoy en día en
el que el ejército ocupa hoy en día
parece que es troncal
esta cuestión no cristiano y equilibrio
que tiene que tener el ejército en este
momento respecto a la figura del
presidente no kristen bueno creo que es
importante de pensar también que el
vicepresidente es un general entonces el
gobierno bolsonaro se hace con los
militares pero hay una presión cada vez
más fuerte en el congreso que está junto
también con los militares entonces por
ejemplo en este movimiento el versión no
tiene un presupuesto público aprobado
para 2020 uno lo que pasa tenemos un
proyecto de presupuesto que hicimos
solar o firma sabes que hace un crimen
fiscal como puede llevar al impeachment
pero si no firma el presupuesto sabes
que el congreso tiene más de una centena
de pedidos en bits bent entonces con un
poco como está entre la espada y la
pared
cristian wing sabin que es cree que es
inevitable esta situación de
polarización política con la que vamos a
llegar a 2022 que se va a instalar este
escenario en la post tándem en brasil y
se va a instalar y sobre todo se va va a
seguir porque el vacío del curso que ya
tenían de 2018 con el precedente y la
historia de ese momento muy fuerte del
de la de la barato del asunto la barato
que polariza va el debate político
totalmente y contribuía a que se
desenvolviera un odio un odio político
entró dentro de los dos campos me quedo
sin timo para más muchísimas gracias a
los tres por haberme acompañado hoy en
este en este gran programa que hemos
hecho sobre brasil explicando desde la
parte más sanitaria hacia la parte más
económica y todo el escenario político
que se presenta de cara a 2022 ya todos
ustedes les esperamos aquí en primera
plana la próxima semana muchas gracias